un achat sur deux est effectué via le
réseau internet est contesté ce chiffre
montre bien le manque de fiabilité de ce
type de tennant alors pour renforcer la
sécurité à nouveau procédé va être
commercialisé dans deux semaines
il s'agit du cyber comme c'est un
boîtier que l'on peut installer chez soi
qui est l'équivalent des terminaux qui
sont utilisées par des commerçants mais
ce gage de sécurité a un prix 400 francs
pour le particulier qui veut son équipe
et reportages cyrille devaud et m'a dit
diawara le cyber comme c'est ce petit
moitié il ressemble comme deux gouttes
d'eau au terminal de paiement que l'on
trouve chez les commerçants ou le
brancher directement à votre ordinateur
pour régler un achat sur internet il
suffit d'insérer sa carte à puce dans le
lecteur et de valider son code secret à
quatre chiffres
jusqu'à présent il fallait simplement
donner son numéro de carte à 16 chiffres
sans taper de code secret pour payer sur
le net un système peut sécuriser une
transaction sur deux était soumise à
litige avec le cyber comme le paiement
est crypté sur le réseau l'information
ne passe plus chez le commerçant
le cyber comme interroge directement
votre banque
une fois lâché validé le commerçant est
sûr d'être payé
les inventeurs du système nous
promettent une sécurité et une
confidentialité totale
la transaction est comme on dit en
anglais
online 100% c'est à dire que toutes les
transactions vont remonter jusqu'à la
banque du porteur et contrôler et donc
il peut pas y avoir de fraude à ce
niveau là puisque seul votre banque peut
l'ouvrir il doit de connaître la
signature de la cac les commerçants du
web qui voudront utiliser le logiciel
cybercom devront payer une commission de
son côté l'internaute devra acheter le
boîtier 400 font environ ce sont donc
les utilisateurs et pas les fabricants
de la carte bancaire qui vont assumer le
prix de la sécurité
la meilleure solution c'était quand même
de l'intégrer directement soit de le
donner ou de le prêter comme comme on
l'a fait pour le minitel où on ne
prêtait soit
inclure directement dans les ordinateurs
mais ça à titre gratuit puisque le
système c'est eux qu'ils fournissent et
sait tous qu'il paye on sait que les
systèmes c'est leur responsabilité
le succès ou l'échec du cyber comme
indiquera sans aucun doute si les
français sont prêts ou non à se
convertir au commerce électronique